MODERATOR: cloud.
MODERATOR: Okay, now we are recording and now i'm going to give you a remote control.
MODERATOR: You should be able to move your.
MODERATOR: legs one, second, let me, let me take out there, my face.
MODERATOR: But yeah it's fine go ahead, go ahead.
P1: So I seem to have control area.
perfect.
P1: Okay, so you deserve other tasks.
MODERATOR: tasks and in the informed consent.
MODERATOR: right they have started page for.
P1: So you want me to read those now.
MODERATOR: If you can go one by one, and then do the tasks and i'm going to be timing these tasks.
Okay.
P1: So i'm going to read it out loud.
MODERATOR: Yes, please.
P1: read the text within the home tab in the main panel allowed explore data source of your choosing by right clicking and opening in a new tab.
P1: Once you feel you understand where the data comes from click the button open.
P1: To visualize the density of data points medications of interest to be done when you mentioned a few the analyze that data points available.
P1: Okay, so.
P1: You don't have control anymore.
P1: it's very slow.
P1: High and escape dashboard dashboard hides the complexities and linkedin.
P1: Clinical rare disease data with environment observations using knowledge, crafts, the desired outcome is to support health data researchers identify appropriate.
P1: Environmental variables, to enable your hypothesis exploration in research and rare disease.
P1: and select and submit the query inputs on the Left explore the resulting linked environmental data that appear after clicking submit export the data for your needs.
P1: A text file named user query history is automatically saved local folder.
P1: With the history of a query input selections will be able to use this file to get the data directly through an API and future.
P1: Data or environmental observations gathered from the following sources, whether pollution and aerosol data.
P1: Data points density click the point and hover over to get the data points okay so.
P1: Open map.
P1: I can see here that.
P1: Pollution in Dublin to 27 data points three whether.
P1: it's data points sensitive 30.
P1: Cork, the data point St 11.
P1: Always data point that says three.
P1: query using the input options available in the query tab on the left, most panel.
P1: or a slice the query options, please explain the last two choices, you make, as you make choices new ones will become available for you to select.
P1: Once you reach the end, please click the submit button.
P1: Okay, you will be done when a new tab name q1 is displayed in the main panel.
P1: Okay, so.
P1: Sorry i'm sorry rare disease.
P1: is quite a lag here I just know from your timing through the zoom.
P1: event of interest.
you've got a nice little.
P1: pop up there doesn't disappear, though.
P1: Unless you click it again okay.
P1: Definitely.
P1: Possible there should be an all there, I think.
P1: that combines definitely high probability can possible.
P1: and
P1: So try to take high probable where you can click multiple okay good.
P1: That allows you to combine okay that's good.
P1: So the dates.
P1: it's showing me Li Carlo Kevin identical.
P1: These are the event dates, where there has been flares.
P1: And I presume there's there's only three shown here and put to seven pages.
P1: So dub and obviously has a lot more.
P1: Okay, so this is just summarizing all the dates, where there has been flares.
P1: And our location of interests say Dublin.
P1: And you can select more than one.
P1: Day range so it's not clear that this is a.
P1: date field, I just clicked on that I just found that there was one there and.
P1: i'm just kind of struggling to get down there.
MODERATOR: yeah I think it was a bit of luck.
P1: and also the.
P1: I can't see the.
P1: calendar and.
MODERATOR: You can you.
MODERATOR: can use does the scrolling work for you yeah well, you have to click here sorry.
P1: yeah it's difficult because I.
P1: mean i'll try and pick something else.
P1: kind of write it in.
P1: And there's a lot there's a big lag actually so it's.
P1: very hard to reason it's very light Gray and.
P1: 2018.
P1: Oh wait.
P1: Okay, so I think it down there now.
P1: Though having to click.
P1: Through the months is not ideal, you should be able to click it to the years back, I think.
P1: The data sources temporary and it's.
MODERATOR: for the experiment only data from 2020 is available.
MODERATOR: Okay, because I accounted for the like in this room and then my using my computer and everything.
P1: data sources, whether.
P1: pick one of those can your.
P1: brother or pollution or both.
P1: And let's just go through whether.
P1: Anyone really dating month here in a very temporary units.
P1: don't think you'd ever need directly or even a.
P1: spatial temporal aggregation made Min Max.
P1: And you can only select one of those okay.
P1: So I don't exactly scenario where you only need man for Max you would need main median or Min Max both together.
P1: And let's go for this domain.
P1: Now this is presumably accessing some kind of triple store.
P1: So I completed the task down with I.
yeah.
P1: I just explore this anyway, so you can.
P1: query and put some description keisha.
MODERATOR: You want to read the next task.
P1: Okay.
P1: tables Nice, there are two buttons that hope you interpret the data that you see.
P1: click those buttons on top opening quick query input some rain open.
P1: table description.
P1: hey so i'm clicking on open query and put summary.
P1: will create and put summary, this gives you options rare disease.
P1: event of interest location of interest on the data.
P1: So this is.
P1: Over two pages i'm not sure whether that could appear on one, but you need to have to.
P1: So this just summarizes what we've put in.
P1: And clicking on the open table description.
P1: So the data data table data table background, so I think that should be two words.
P1: If data is normally distributed 90% 5% should be between minus two plus two is that scores and they're quite.
P1: It doesn't just say what if if the data is not normally distributed what happens like that would be useful to know.
P1: and values are grazing to our high value customize to I know Okay, so your.
P1: Simple score for that.
P1: Okay, then read the text in the data sub tab.
P1: and talk through the interpretation of variables are self evident colors.
P1: Okay.
P1: Excellent data sub tab.
P1: The variables, the units appear when hovering over the headings detached table.
P1: for further information first data sources in the home tab okay toggle columns highlights select an extract.
P1: And extract button, I think you mean export button.
P1: and
P1: Okay, so.
P1: You can scroll vertically and horizontally and use a page arrows to check the meditation that you're querying i'm not sure if my pager I was what helped me here.
MODERATOR: No that's that's that's for me to control some stuff.
P1: and
P1: i'll try using my.
P1: Stop stop there.
MODERATOR: there's there's no more.
Okay.
P1: So we've got.
P1: Basically, seven months here as a whole dataset.
P1: and
P1: I guess it's not clarify that that score applies to just this data or the whole dataset.
P1: So you've got an average temperature.
P1: wet bulb you know, does he say pressure means he'll have a pressure wind speed.
P1: Okay.
P1: So I think i've done number three.
P1: Although we don't see any red or blue.
P1: fields.
P1: yeah so there's no right or two fields there, so I presume.
P1: That these values within this very restricted data sets are within the 75 or 95% confidence intervals.
P1: Okay, so what's not clear to me, is exactly what we're looking at here.
P1: So this is only referring to.
P1: don't see how it relates to the patients.
P1: So we have it looks like about 40 events.
P1: In Dublin, with the dates now, the issue here is that there were no dates within 2020.
P1: So.
P1: I don't understand how this relates to patients I think what you're showing me here is.
P1: Basically, a summary for.
P1: For 2020.
P1: But it doesn't have any relationship to the patient.
P1: Because, Sir, there are no patients with that, during that time period, so I think for running to the thing you might.
P1: expand your time period, so you definitely are events within that period.
MODERATOR: task for.
P1: The other tabs beside the data tab or three plots time series box plot plot are attractive features just purchase a piece those features for.
P1: Each mentioning usefulness.
P1: OK, we have our time series.
P1: lot of variables on this and they're a little the same they're just plotted against said score okay.
yeah.
P1: there's a bit of a lag here so that's probably why it's difficult so so this thing at the bottom here is the full intro.
P1: And you can.
P1: click on this to zoom in and using the upper one that's what i'm seeing this is happening.
P1: Very cool.
P1: Thank you move your window back and forth.
P1: I can see here and they're kind of February first was a little bit outside their normal.
P1: Okay, so last time series very nice.
P1: X plus.
P1: shows, if you hover over, you can see, the actual values.
P1: And you have a portion here medium.
P1: So I assume the failure report medium that you have determined that the data is not only distributed.
P1: And if it was your report to me.
P1: that's a deviation.
P1: And so.
P1: So.
P1: Again, I think, for for ease you know these names of each along the X axis here.
P1: and
P1: The recipe, I mean I kind of know them, but it might be hard for a new person to understand what msl means, for example.
P1: So you might need something to where you can hover over that.
P1: To expand, or else have the the actual name of what it is.
P1: In there and in the X axis.
P1: Okay, so these are just bucks plus the other scenes there are little dots as well, I think these mushrooms, these represent as far as perhaps.
P1: A quick here what they mean.
P1: question comes up here mean.
P1: Take a snapshot.
P1: that's not responding now.
P1: Chris I took a snapshot or last push.
P1: My okay so let's just save it.
MODERATOR: You can cancel those notes at my computer, please.
P1: Okay it's disappeared on me now, so I don't see that box anymore.
Okay.
P1: You can cancel it if you want.
P1: Okay.
P1: i'm excited to see what progress.
P1: I don't see okay so.
P1: So you can only select one variable for this.
P1: yeah that's not what this means that say.
MODERATOR: Would you mind reading the text.
P1: Complex variable when dependencies radius length indicates the wind speed.
P1: And the degrees of interaction visualization is interactive.
P1: sure what each of these points means so.
P1: Is it a day or.
P1: And why is rain clicked what is.
P1: The temperature, what does that too.
P1: So I mean the store down the bottom left so.
P1: When does down that direction and.
P1: capture 5.8 and the color Of these, which is a bit hard to see.
P1: The colors and.
P1: reflects the temperature on those days, so what you're seeing here is a combination of wind speed and direction plus temperature.
P1: I think that you know that this might be a bit too much for.
P1: me, certainly for this purpose bit too much to take in and for someone's brain.
P1: And, but it's a nice way of exploring wind direction which has always been a problem.
P1: Okay, so i've explored all three they're.
P1: Great tune your queries after you've submitted them follow following the same instructions in step two two new queries using step two.
P1: You will see q2 q3 as new tabs on the main panel Nathan compare them the proprietor tab read the text in this tab and select the number of groups who wish to make.
P1: Then click on click to generate groups I new inputs will per group will appear underneath.
P1: Right your queries in the group's click on click to plot groups.
P1: So the question you query.
P1: tricky.
P1: possible.
P1: So I mean one of the options here is no flare so i'm not quite sure what that means I guess it takes.
P1: All the encounters.
P1: Where flair is not mentioned.
P1: So this time we're going to look at.
P1: What this little button means.
P1: it's a Cork.
P1: K.
P1: date range for all perhaps here, this is an easy one.
P1: This time.
P1: can see, there are some right about now.
P1: PM 10pm 2.5 or 25 is not care.
P1: guess, we can have real rush to clarify okay it's clear.
P1: This is just one page.
P1: one page preach month.
P1: hey.
P1: Krishna query.
P1: The same inputs.
P1: Just like to look at.
P1: You know, two is important, you know collects to Disney.
P1: Simplified it now.
P1: See quite easily now.
P1: always just one month per page so just have that mixture here.
P1: And each line is a.
P1: red and blue, I think, maybe.
P1: You might have a quotation of red.
P1: Light red for just above 95%.
P1: Maybe 99% of a dark red or something like that cemetery on the blue.
P1: Okay, so i'm assuming here that each line represents one encounter.
P1: Maybe it's still not clear to me about that, but.
P1: Anyway, we're going to try and and comparison buddies now.
P1: And the comparison tub.
P1: Time series for this.
MODERATOR: You if you want to read it again mark.
P1: You two new tabs on the main hell yeah.
P1: Now you can compare them to the comparative top.
P1: Okay.
P1: read the text in this tab and select groups, you wish to make.
P1: Created previously submitted a session can be compared by specific variable.
P1: You can combine these queries into two into groups, the multiple selection inputs to potentially increase the exit signal to noise ratio.
P1: decide the number of groups that you wish to compare select which queries you want to group.
P1: explore environmental variables, the different plots.
P1: crazy grouped by computing the mean year per unit of time, the time series plotting the constant concatenate.
P1: The values in the box and distribution plots.
P1: Therefore, the time series plot has a limitation of comparing queries with different timing it's.
P1: Okay.
P1: Can.
P1: generate groups, you had quotes per quick clip here underneath ranger queries groups and pick up groups.
P1: Combined to I guess one.
P1: Nice feature.
P1: Time series bucks plush and distribution.
P1: Nothing there, yes.
P1: I have to select something here so unfair to compare the groups so i'd like to.
P1: So the problem here as such.
P1: We haven't.
P1: Put comparing, whether in one position and another so cool about her.
P1: Maybe i'll Just compare two and three.
P1: So this tells the number of groups.
P1: That have seen.
MODERATOR: You can't see because this room over there screaming sorry like I can try to fix it give me a second yeah.
P1: Okay, here we go.
P1: Okay, there you go to okay.
P1: let's try again just comparing the ones.
P1: got this error message.
MODERATOR: me and we take it up and.
MODERATOR: I cannot, I cannot control the mouse.
P1: We take.
P1: So we have group one group too much outside.
P1: emissaries.
P1: I can only see the red one.
P1: I don't see it.
MODERATOR: Go to click the red one, please.
P1: Okay.
MODERATOR: They are actually the same quality, because you put it on the same let's let's move on as.
P1: well.
P1: Too so it's the same area so same location.
P1: But.
P1: Because there are no events in 2020 is that right.
P1: and
P1: Aside from query to.
P1: Okay, so.
P1: Over time and again, we can.
P1: show a nice little.
P1: window.
P1: peek there.
P1: Okay.
P1: Okay, so you have the bucks Plus we have the individual values.
P1: are clearly not normally distributed.
P1: This value is.
P1: To mean I guess.
P1: yeah, so it is it's not clear which what these are what these dots represent you know so.
P1: This kind of linkage to the flare event, I think, might be at the root of some of this these problems.
P1: and
P1: Try distribution.
P1: that's not exactly what this means here.
P1: shows up here what's on the y axis here either.
P1: and
P1: I don't really understand this, plus.
P1: So presuming each one of these what's on the X axis is.
P1: days are not sure.
P1: So is present, maybe the X axis is the PM 2.5 valued.
P1: And this is the.
P1: distribution of values.
P1: and
P1: Okay, so you can see that this so it's basically a histogram.
P1: yeah you might kind of use the word histogram rather than just.
P1: that's clearly right skewed.
P1: Here as well, so that's Okay, so I need to.
P1: arrange your queries groups and click on the clock groups now he's appeared to be fraser's piece.
P1: Okay, so I think I finished that one them.
P1: and choose one of the queries to export q1 q2 Austrian close that tab click the export button from the data table.
P1: to download the data as a csv file finally open the zip downloads tab on the left side and.
P1: I don't know tip with all these tables to download all days for all the queries in session as a zip file.
P1: Okay.
MODERATOR: Please continue, please.
MODERATOR: If you can please can't even save it to my computer, please.
P1: Castle where.
MODERATOR: What I bless it you can't you can go ahead, no.
P1: Okay, so you don't want to export.
No thanks.
P1: And the zip data tab left side panel.
P1: tables from this query Okay, I want to press.
MODERATOR: This one just to see what happens.
P1: files.
P1: This you have a choice should be cut to downloads.
P1: So.
P1: that's where we are.
P1: summarize my experiences well it's really impressive means of.
P1: Exploring data.
P1: and
P1: I think a little bit like last time.
P1: it's not clear what the objectives are here i'm not sure.
P1: You know the in terms of design of this for the users have been incorporated sufficient here in Austin and.
P1: It seems like.
P1: We are.
P1: Providing a value in the data table and in the in the graphs.
P1: For each encounter.
P1: The best data from that encounter.
P1: I presume is the data from the county in which that encounter encounter occurred, rather than from the encounter itself.
P1: And it reflects the prevailing the prevailing.
P1: Whether or pollution values on that day.
P1: or in that month, so if you want to link this to kind of a by a biological our experimental research question.
P1: As we've discussed many times in the adverb project.
P1: The.
P1: If we're looking at flare events, we need to understand the prevailing pollution weather data in a period before the slayer.
P1: So there's a pro travel period, you know it really doesn't matter what the the weather's like of the day, or even so many of the month, because the month presumably will be the calendar month.
P1: And so the flare that may have happened, you know so sorry that happened at the end of the color calendar months, then.
P1: That might be helpful because it's the period, probably 123 or four weeks before the flare event.
P1: Or maybe even longer, because the patient doesn't always attend hospital immediately.
P1: that's The big challenge with all of this work is you know understanding that program will period.
P1: and
P1: So I think you probably need if you if you wanted, if this is going to be applied for this purpose and.
P1: They need something there that allows you to define a lag.
P1: You know the period where you can say well i'd like to see the data.
P1: You know one week two week three week or four weeks before the event or the encountering question.
P1: and
P1: And I think it's.
P1: yeah, so I think that, I mean the explorations really nice, yes, a few little bits where it's a bit tricky and there's a lag made it a bit more difficult as well, but you know it's very nicely laid out and.
P1: Your time series is really nice like that and.
P1: But when we're exploring this from a research point of view, where.
P1: we're almost certainly never going to look at an individual patients, you know it's.
P1: We need to have you know, large numbers of patients in each group.
P1: So I think reporting aggregate values is probably more important than exploring the individual patients but.
P1: But again, having access to the data table to show where the data is coming from, is also it's also useful and.
P1: yeah, so I think and it's it's quite intuitive in terms of running the test, I think I get people to read this the tasks before out so you got an idea took me a little while to.
P1: to work out what he wants me to do next.
P1: So, but yeah I mean it's a very famous very good to see us there and.
P1: see it in action, and I can certainly see this kind of approach.
P1: that's having a lot of applications beyond environment.
P1: The first one, I think, to think about is cider.
P1: You know the computerized infectious disease registry.
P1: That would be.
P1: Not too not too difficult, I mean basically it's the same thing in the sense that you have.
P1: For a given month, you have a number at a location and there might be a bit of good locations are not exactly matching your one so.
P1: and also the in terms of the environmental data.
P1: and
P1: You are deriving.
P1: From the actual weather stations, whereas I really think.
P1: You know I think you, you probably can't do that you know because.
P1: Inevitably we've had lots of meetings with chuck Gallagher about this is that, certainly with pollution.
P1: it's.
P1: There are so few pollution stations that you cannot tell what the patient's be as close to by looking at a station.
P1: that have hit the measurements from that station and.
P1: You need some kind of land use regression or something else that interprets the value for.
P1: A given pollutant.
P1: and
P1: This generally means what these interpolation things do they take a lot of different data sources, they take the local measurement, but they also use satellite data.
P1: You know, we have adopted this across of ours.
P1: Whereas you kind of seem to have gone a different way.
P1: And again, I think, early engagement with the wider team would it be important to identify that.
P1: So.
P1: yeah but I mean Actually, I mean the sources of data basically from Copernicus and.
P1: Global sources of data that's pretty easy to get access to that and use it as a data source, instead, perhaps you can think about man.
P1: yeah.
MODERATOR: Stop the recording.